Welcome to chapter three, Nutrients, Membrains and Transport.
In this chapter, we're going to look at those concepts, but we're also going to be asking
the question, "Is it possible to supplement your way to better performance and health?"
We live in a world today where supplements and vitamins and other nutrients are readily
available to buy separately from the foods that we eat, but do they really work?
Do they make us healthier and do they make us perform better?
Ginkgo to improve memory, Kava to reduce stress, ginseng to boost energy, and melatonin to
help you sleep.
Sounds like a recipe for success, doesn't it?
For good measure, chase those supplements down with some coconut water to slow aging
and prevent cancer.
You might have heard claims like this before, vitamins, minerals, herbs, yeast, and even
enzymes that are claiming to help you be healthier or to perform better in different tasks in
your life.
And another positive with these things is that they come in a bottle and they can stay
on your shelf and stay good with a longer expiration date than the fresh foods that you
might buy from a grocery store.
Instead of going to a store every weekend and throwing away food that you never get
around to eating, you could stock your pantry with things like energy drinks, vitamin enriched
waters, protein powders, nutrition bars, and other bottles of vitamins and minerals.
You could even buy them in bulk if you like because they won't rot like fruits and vegetables.
But are they as good for you as you might think or as the advertisement might say?
Is it possible to supplement your way to enhance academic performance and even better
health and even physical performance?
It seems most Americans think so because we spend around $6 billion a year in America
on these items and more than 2/3 of us are taking at least one type of supplement.
But let's investigate whether these products are really doing what we hope that they're
doing and while we're asking that question, we'll learn about biological concepts like
nutrients, cells, and membrane transport.
Here's our learning outcomes.
As stated in the textbook of this chapter, be sure to read through them and recognize
them as you come across them in your notes in your reading.
Do you use any of these types of supplements like ginkgo, cava, ginseng, melatonin, or
coconut water, or do you use some other supplements that are not on this list?
Well like we said, American spends about $6 billion per year on supplements and 2/3 of
us are taking at least one.
Well in order to figure out if these things are actually working and what the body needs
to be healthy and to perform well, let's first look at nutrients.
First of all macronutrients, mackerel again means big, so these are nutrients that come
in a large form that your body would have to digest first in order to make use of them.
Digest means to break them down into smaller particles.
Nutrients are substances that come in the foods that we eat and after we break them down
by digestion it provides a structural material for the body to build other things or it provides
the body with energy to do work.
Macronutrients are required in large amounts and they include water, carbohydrates, proteins,
and fats.
We studied water in our last chapter and we learned about properties of water.
Water consists of one atom of oxygen and two atoms of hydrogen combined together by covalent
bonds that are really strong, but also remember they are combined in a way in which oxygen
gets to spend a little more time with those electrons that they're sharing with the hydrogens
because oxygen is more electronegative.
So it causes a polarity to the molecule where oxygen has a net negative charge and hydrogen
has a net positive charge.
So because of the polarity of a water molecule, charges on opposite ends, it sets up that
molecule to have some properties that we discussed last chapter such as being a great solvent
to dissolve ions and other molecules, it's the universal solvent, doesn't dissolve everything
but it does dissolve a lot of things.
So in the body we say it disperses nutrients really well and we're made up of a large percentage
of water so all of those nutrients that we have are within that water, within our cells
and also within the extracellular fluid as well.
Water molecules also like to stick together, that's called cohesion when that happens.
Even also remember because of the hydrogen bonds between water molecules, those bonds
have to be broken first before water will change its speed and such when it's heating
up or cooling down, so water resists temperatures, temperature changes, so it's a really good
regulator for temperature for our body and for our environment and those are all good
things about it, it dissolves and eliminates waste products as well.
So how many liters of water are lost by an average human each day?
Well the answer there is actually three liters.
Through sweating, urinating and in feces, three liters are lost each day.
One and a half liters will be replaced by the foods we eat and one and a half will need
to be replaced from other sources.
While we can survive without food for several weeks, survival without water is limited to
just a few days.
When you haven't had enough water, you get dehydrated.
One is decreased water intake.
You might even start feeling symptoms when you haven't had enough water.
Minor symptoms include muscle cramps, fatigue, headache, dizziness, nausea, confusion and
even an increased heart rate.
That last one is due to a decreased blood volume when you're dehydrated so your heart
tries to compensate for that effect by speeding up as it tries to maintain homeostasis.
When you're severely dehydrated, things like hallucinations, heat stroke and even death
can result.
One of the major ways that you lose water is through sweating.
It's the evaporation of water from the skin and it helps to cool the body down by releasing
energy as the water molecules leave your skin.
It helps you maintain your body temperature.
When water is low and sweating decreases, body temperature can rise to a harmful level.
Therefore, you need to replace what you lose.
Although it works quite well to replace the water with tap water, many people drink bottled
water, in part because of concerns about the quality of tap water.
However, the U.S. Food and Drug Administration, the FDA, the government agency that sets standards
for bottled water is responsible for ensuring food safety in general and uses the same standards
applied by the Environmental Protection Agency or the EPA to ensure that tap water is helpful.
In other words, water from both sources should be equally clean.
In fact, nearly 40% of bottled water actually contains water just from municipal tap water.
Many people might choose to rehydrate themselves with sports drinks.
But studies have shown that hydrating with water is actually better for athletes than
hydrating with costly sports drinks.
So sports drinks can come with other additives, such as sugars that provide unneeded calories
or additives that have unproven benefits, and it costs more than water.
Yes, bottled water and other sports drinks come in bottles that are convenient and portable,
but it does come at a cost to the environment.
Those billions of bottles used each year require 1.5 million barrels of oil to produce.
Although the bottles are recyclable, 86% of those bottles go to landfills each year.
In addition, the energy required to transport water FAR exceeds the energy required to
purify an equivalent amount of just plain old tap water.
Besides obtaining a healthy dose of water each day, people need to consume foods that
contain macronutrients like carbohydrates, proteins, and fats.
In our last chapter, we discussed those in more detail and their structures.
On of those, what molecules are the major source of energy for ourselves?
The source of energy that allows us to create our very own energy molecules called ATP.
Well, the answer to that is carbohydrates.
Carbohydrates are a macronutrient and our main energy source.
It's the main energy source that we use to quickly produce ATP, our own body's energy
molecule.
It's relatively easy to get the amount of carbohydrates that we need each day in our
diet.
They come in food sources that tend to be relatively easy to prepare and to obtain,
such as bread, cereals, rice, pasta, fruits, and vegetables.
Remember that carbohydrates are a macromolecule, they're very large, and they're made out
of their monomer or repeating subunits called simple sugars.
When it's just one simple sugar by itself, it's called a monosaccharide, and they can
also be made out of long chains of these simple sugars, and when it's that case, it's called
the polysaccharide.
The single unit simple sugars are digested, and they enter the bloodstream quickly after
you eat them.
More sugars found in many of the foods we eat, milk, juice, honey, and most of the refined
foods that we eat contain branching chains that are called complex carbohydrates.
Complex carbohydrates are found in fruits, vegetables, breads, legumes, and in pasta as
well.
Small simple sugars, like glucose and fructose, are digested into the bloodstream very quickly.
The body digests complex carbohydrates much more slowly than it does those simpler sugars
because the complex carbohydrates have more chemical bonds, and then thus would need to
have more digestion break them down.
Endurance athletes often load up on complex carbohydrates for several days before a race
to increase the amount of stored energy that will be available during their competition.
Ideally, we would hope the carbohydrates would be from food rather than dietary supplements.
Nutritionists agree that most of the carbohydrates in a helpful diet should be in the form of
complex carbohydrates, and that it's best to consume only minimal amounts of processed
sugars.
It is a processed food, you might ask, well, it's refined foods that are stripped of their
nutritional value.
They've gone through a process of extensive refinement, and therefore, some are much of
the nutrient value has been stripped as well.
For example, unrefined raw brown sugar is made from the juice of a sugar cane plant, and
it contains minerals and nutrients that are also found in the plant.
Processing brown sugar produces refined brown sugar, like the kind most of us buy at a grocery
store, and that results in the loss of those vitamins and minerals.
Foods that haven't been stripped of their nutrition by processing are called whole foods.
Whole grains, beans, and many fruits and vegetables are whole foods, and in addition to being nutritious,
whole foods tend to be good sources of what you might call dietary fiber.
Sometimes we also call fiber roughage.
Fiber is an important part of a healthy diet.
It's composed mainly of the complex carbohydrates that humans can't digest, such as plants have
cell walls surrounding their cells.
These cell walls are made out of a sugar called cellulose, and we don't have any enzymes to
digest that cellulose.
So you might ask, "Well, if we can't digest it, why do we eat this then?"
Well, we call that cellulose fiber or roughage, and it stays in our digestive tract and passes
into our large intestine, it also helps to draw water into the digestive system as it's
passing.
This fiber and roughage gives bulk to our feces.
Fiber is not a nutrient because it's not absorbed by the body, but as you can see from the description
I just gave you, it is part of a healthful diet and helps to keep an individual regular
with their bowel movements, helps you also to maintain healthy cholesterol levels, and
might even decrease your risk for certain cancers.
Well, what if you don't like things like lettuce and green leafy vegetables, which contain
a lot of fiber?
How about fiber bars?
We tend to see a lot of those on grocery store shelves.
Yes, they may be rich in different types of fiber, but usually they're also rich in processed
sugars and other additives that have a non-nutritive value, therefore it's best to get your fiber
from whole foods.
Our next macronutrient is proteins, another one of those macromolecules that you need
daily to be healthy proteins, make up parts of cellular structures, and also they're so
important they take part in most body processes, such as when they act like enzymes, to make
certain reactions occur within the body.
They're so important that our DNA codes for proteins, and then those proteins make you.
Food sources where you can get them include beef, poultry, fish, beans, eggs, nuts, and
dairy products like milk, yogurt, and cheeses.
In our last chapter we discussed the structural composition of proteins.
Remember the repeating subunit, or monomer unit, that proteins are made from are called
amino acids, and that there's about 20 different amino acids that make up the proteins that
are in our body.
DNA codes for those amino acids to be chained in the right order, and then other cell components
will fold those chains of amino acids into just the right shape so those proteins can
do the job that they need to do.
From what you eat, your body is actually able to synthesize or assemble many of the commonly
occurring amino acids that our proteins are made out of.
There are some, however, out of those 20 amino acids that our bodies cannot synthesize on
their own.
These are called essential amino acids.
You must get these by eating the proper foods.
Complete proteins contain all the essential amino acids that your body needs.
Proteins obtained by eating meat are probably the most likely to be complete than those
obtained by eating plants.
Therefore, if you're vegetarian, it's good to eat a variety of different types of plants
and beans so that you're sure to get those essential amino acids.
True or false, adding protein powder to your post-workout snack is always a healthy way
to add muscle.
Actually that answer is false.
People looking to gain muscle mass will sometimes supplement their diet with protein powders.
That can be mixed with milk or water, and it supposedly helps them rebuild protein-rich
muscle after a strenuous workout.
However, extra protein does not always lead to extra muscle.
Just like any other nutrient in the body, excess protein is stored as, you guessed it,
fat.
So, if you eat too much protein, you'll just stand up increasing your body fat content.
In addition, diets that are too rich in protein can lead to health problems like bone loss
and kidney damage.
If you're looking to build muscle, the most sensible thing to do is to combine your workout
regimen with a healthy diet.
Even the most active people, like endurance athletes, can easily obtain enough protein
by just having a healthy regular diet.
Fats are our next macronutrient.
Fat is stored, energy.
In fact, gram-for-gram fat contains about two times the amount of energy as carbohydrates
are protein-doped.
Foods that are rich in fat include meat, milk, cheeses, vegetable oils, and nuts.
Most mammals, including us humans, store fat just below the skin, which helps protect our
vital organs and give us insulation from those cold Minnesota winters, and also a great place
to store energy just in case famines should occur.
In our last chapter we discussed the composition of fat in its most common form as triglycerides
consists of a molecule of glycerol, which has three carbon atoms, attached to a number
of between one, two, or three fatty acid tails.
Those fatty acid tails consist of carbon and hydrogen bonded together and have a lot of
potential energy for the body.
Our body can synthesize most of the fatty acids that it requires.
Those that can't be synthesized by itself are called essential fatty acids.
Just like essential amino acids, essential fatty acids need to be obtained from the diet
that you eat, so you need to eat foods that are rich in these essential fatty acids, as
well as the essential amino acids we discussed previously.
Omega-3 and Omega-6 fatty acids are essential fatty acids, and we can get these very easily
by just eating fish.
They're thought to help to protect against heart disease, and nutritionists recommend
people eat about 12 ounces of fish every week.
Some people who don't eat much fish supplement their diets with fish oil capsules, however,
if you just obtain your fish oil with capsules, you're missing out on all those other vitamins
and nutrients that actually eating fish gives you.
A fatty acid tail contains carbon that's double bonded to another carbon, which fat has this
structure?
Well, it's called an unsaturated fat, and you've probably heard about these or read that name
on nutrition labels for the foods that you buy.
Here's some pictures to help you visualize that.
And all the carbons are single bonded to the hydrogens near them.
It creates a nice fatty acid chain that's just pretty linear.
Because of this, these types of fats, called saturated fats, have the maximum amount of
hydrogens possible, and they compact really easily.
So it's said that these types of fats, saturated fats, contribute more to problems with the
cardiovascular system, such as buildup of plaques in our arteries.
These types of fats tend to be solid at room temperature like butter and come from animals.
Types of fats, as you can see in the picture here, that have in the fatty acid chain some
carbons that are double bonded to one another and therefore less hydrogens have kinks within
the fatty acid chains.
Therefore, you see they don't sit as linear and as flat as the saturated fats do.
Therefore, these are called unsaturated fats because they don't sit so flat they tend to
be liquid at room temperature, tend to come from vegetables, like vegetable oil and from
fish, and they say that these do not contribute as much to cardiovascular problems as the saturated
fats do.
However, you still want to utilize moderation when eating fats.
Here's a chart to summarize that.
Saturated fats, once again, have carbons with single bonds to as many hydrogens as possible.
That's why they're called saturated, they're saturated with as many hydrogens as possible.
They lack double bonds, they're solid at room temperature, and they come from animals.
Unsaturated fats, because of those double bonds, between the carbons contain fewer hydrogens
and those double bonds cause kinks in the fatty acid chains.
This makes them not sit as flat and compacted together, therefore they tend to be liquid
at room temperature and come from plants and vegetables.
The more double bonds that there are in the fatty acid chains, the higher the degree of
unsaturation, and when fat contains many unsaturated carbons, the fat is referred to as polyunsaturated.
A good source of polyunsaturated fats is cooking oil, like corn oil or vegetable oil.
Commercial food manufacturers sometimes add hydrogen atoms to unsaturated fats by combining
hydrogen gas with vegetable oils under pressure.
That process is called hydrogenation.
It increases the level of saturation of the fat, or basically it adds more hydrogens and
breaks up some of those carbon double bonds and replaces them with hydrogen instead in
the fatty acid tails of the fat molecule.
They do that process to make the liquid actually a little more solidified and extends its shelf
life a bit, so margarine is a vegetable oil that has undergone hydrogenation.
Unfortunately, this process creates something called trans fats.
They're produced by incomplete hydrogenation, which also changes the structure of the fatty
acid tails in the fat so that even though there's mostly carbon-carbon double bonds, the fatty
acids are flat and not kinked.
For our bodies, these fats are not required, nor are they beneficial.
In fact, research has indicated they're very unhealthy.
If you choose to eat energy bars, protein bars, fiber bars, and other nutrition bars,
it's best to look for those that do not contain trans fats.
There's health risks of consuming those foods that have trans fats in them.
They include clogged arteries, heart disease, and increased risk of diabetes.
A final note on fats because they contain more stored energy program than carbs or proteins.
Excess fat intake is associated with several diseases, like the ones listed above, so overall
in your diet, try to limit fat intake and try to choose the healthier fats as well.
So on to micronutrients, vitamins are micronutrients.
Which vitamin can be synthesized by the human body?
The answer to that is vitamin D. Micronutrients are required in smaller quantities than macronutrients,
hence the prefix micro means small.
Micronutrients include vitamins and minerals.
These are not broken down by the body, they already come as a small structure.
They can go through cell membranes and then are readily used by cells.
They're also not burned for energy.
Vitamins, our first type of micronutrient, are organic substances, most of which the body
cannot synthesize on its own.
Vitamins in the body, most vitamins function as what's called a coenzyme.
A coenzyme is a molecule that helps enzymes and thus helps to speed up that enzymes work
in completing a body's chemical reaction.
Vitamin deficiencies can affect every cell in the body because many different enzymes,
all requiring the same vitamin, are involved in numerous bodily functions.
Vitamins can even help protect the body against cancer and heart disease and even slows the
aging process.
Vitamin D, which is also called calcitriol, is the only vitamin that our cells and our
body can synthesize on their own.
But, there's a catch, sunlight is required for that process, so people living in climates
with little sunlight can more easily develop a deficiency of vitamin D in those areas
than those that live in places where there's plentiful sunlight.
Healthcare providers may recommend vitamin D supplements to these people.
You might also see that milk often comes supplemented with vitamin D.
All other vitamins then must be supplied by the foods that we eat.
Here's a list of some food sources and what vitamins they contain.
Vitamin B12 is found in chicken, fish, red meat, and dairy.
Vitamin C in many fruits and vegetables and meats, vitamin D in milk, egg yolk, and soy.
But remember, we need sunlight to complete that process.
Vitamin E in almonds, oils, mangoes, broccoli, and nuts, and folic acid, which is in dark
green vegetables, nuts, legumes, and in whole grains.
Water soluble vitamins are the ones that are not stored by the body.
So, a lack of water soluble vitamins is more likely the cause of dietary deficiencies than
the lack of fat soluble vitamins.
Vitamins B and C are water soluble.
They can be leached out by boiling, therefore, if you eat canned vegetables, you're probably
not getting a good source of B and C vitamins because the canning process requires boiling.
So, fresh vegetables are a better source of these.
Vitamins A, D, E, and K are fat soluble and build up and stored fat.
In excess of those vitamins accumulated in the body, though, can be toxic.
For those people who take megadosis through supplementation of these fat soluble vitamins,
they can increase the risk of contracting certain cancers, health disease, and it can
even lead to heart disease and death.
Our next micronutrients is minerals.
These are inorganic substances, meaning they do not contain carbon, but they're still essential
for many cell functions.
Because they lack carbon, minerals are said to be the inorganic kind.
They are important for proper fluid balance in muscle contraction and in conduction of
nerve impulses.
They also help us build bones and teeth.
Here's a list of some of the foods where you can find some essential micronutrients like
calcium and milk, cheese, dark green vegetables and legumes, magnesium and spinach, fish,
nuts, seeds, beans, and brown rice, and potassium found in potatoes, tomatoes, bananas, avocados,
and other fresh and dried fruits, dairy, whole grains, and meats.
Like most vitamins, minerals are not synthesized in the body and must be supplied through our
diets.
Calcium is a commonly supplemented mineral.
You can get it through different pills or chewables or even in certain health drinks.
Bodies need calcium.
It helps our blood clot.
It helps muscles contract.
It helps nerves, fire, and bones to grow and stay healthy.
When your dietary calcium is low, your body has to get it from somewhere, so it takes
it from our bones and therefore it weakens bones if we don't have enough calcium in our
blood and in our diet.
If you're not getting enough calcium in your diet, which is around a thousand milligrams
per day, many health care providers will recommend supplements.
Three ounces of yogurt, one and a half ounces of cheese, and one glass of milk together
contain around 1,000 milligrams of calcium.
In addition to vitamins and minerals, antioxidants are also a micronutrient.
Many whole foods contain molecules called these antioxidants.
They help to prevent cells from damage caused by molecules that are generated by normal
cell processes.
These normal molecules are called free radicals and they're highly reactive molecules.
They usually have an incomplete outer electron shell, which makes them more chemically reactive
than other molecules with complete electron shells.
Free radicals can then go and damage cell membranes, the lining of arteries, and even
our DNA.
Antioxidants can inhibit chemical reactions that involve free radicals and decrease the
damage that they do in our cells.
Antioxidants are abundant in fruits, vegetables, nuts, grains, and other meats.
Here's a chart showing some foods that have high levels of antioxidants.
Kinds are beta-carotene, flavanol, and lycopene.
I like the middle one there with flavanol found in cocoa and dark chocolate.
All in all, it seems that the best benefit of antioxidants comes from eating whole foods
and not supplements.
This is mostly likely due to the fact that there needs to be a balance of both antioxidants
and free radicals within our bodies to maintain homeostasis and optimal health.
It is found that some free radicals in our body are needed to be able to kill cancer
cells, bacteria, and invaders.
So there is that balance between having the right amount of antioxidants and free radicals
that keeps us healthy.
Next, let's talk about cells.
Some supplements are composed of extracts produced by grinding and breaking open plant
cells, while there are other supplements that are made to affect a particular subcellular
structure within human cells.
As we learned in our last chapter, cells of the basic unit of life and plant and animal
cells evolved from a common ancestor, therefore they share many characteristics in common,
including their cell structures like ribosomes and organelles like mitochondria.
So first we'll take a look at cells and their structures, their organelles, and then we'll
examine some supplements made from plant cells and some supplements that inhibit organelle
function.
Cells, the basic unit of life, contain cytoplasm.
Cytoplasm includes two parts, cytosol, which is the liquid, and then the organelles, which
are the structures that are in that liquid.
Organelles literally means little organ.
They perform specific jobs that are required by the cells.
They also work with other organelles.
Cytazol is the watery matrix, and it has many different things dissolved within it, like
salts and enzymes, the cytosol houses the organelles.
All cells, no matter if you're a plant, animal, bacteria, fungus or protists, all cells contain
a cell membrane, also called the plasma membrane.
It encloses the cell and defines the outer boundary of the cell from the internal environment
of the cell.
Cell membrane's job is very important, besides being the boundary from the external and internal
environment of the cell.
It determines what materials will be allowed in or out of the cell.
It's semi-permeable, meaning some molecules are able to cross, and those that can't are
prevented from crossing.
As we learned in our last chapter, cell membranes are made out of a type of lipid called the
phospholipid.
That's a type of lipid that has a glycerol and a phosphate head, and then two fatty acid
tails.
One of them is saturated, and the other one is unsaturated, and you can tell that in
the fact that it's kinked.
The end of the head with the phosphate group has a charge, which makes it hydrophilic.
This end does not care that it's sticking into the water of the cytoplasm, the cytosol,
or in the extracellular fluid.
It does not repel that water.
Hydrophilic means water-loving.
The tail ends with the fatty acid chains are not polar or not charged, therefore they stick
inward into two layers, which is called the phospholipid bilayer.
As you can see in this picture here, there's two layers of these phospholipids, but the
tail end is hydrophobic, because it does not have a charge, which most lipids do not,
and therefore they don't want to be touching that water that's within the cytosol or in
the extracellular fluid, so they stick inward.
The cell membrane is said to have fluid properties, which allows these lipids to kind of slide
laterally and change places.
There's also proteins and such that are embedded in the cell membrane as well.
As you can see in the picture here, these proteins have very special jobs.
They often carry out enzymatic functions or certain chemical reactions.
They might serve as a receptor to receive different molecules, like a hormone.
They may also help transport things like substances across the cell membrane, things that can't
dissolve through the phospholipid bilayer, generally then would go through one of these
proteins.
In this picture on this slide, we see a comparison of animal cells versus plant cells.
While they do look very different, they do share many things in common, such as being
eukaryotic.
They have a nucleus with DNA inside.
They have a nucleolus where ribosomes are made.
They have endoplasmic reticulum, which are like transport tubes within the cell.
These little folded membranes here, they contain ribosomes, which are these little dots.
That's where proteins are synthesized.
These little kidney-beam-shaped things are called mitochondria, where we take glucose
and make it into our energy molecule called ATP.
And then one of the big differences you can probably see right away is the plant cell.
It has this big, huge central vacuole.
They also have these green things called chloroplasts, which contain chlorophyll that absorb sunlight
and allow the process of photosynthesis to occur to be able to make glucose.
And then that glucose can be chained together into polysaccharides called starch and then
stored in the central vacuole of the plant cell.
So literally the cell of a plant has its own glucose stores that it can use in the mitochondria
then to make its own ATP.
Plant cells also have this extra structure out here around the membrane called the cell
wall.
Cell walls are generally made out of a sugar called cellulose that I told you about earlier
that we call fiber because we can't digest that cellulose.
You'll see those structures like the cell wall and the central vacuole and the chloroplasts
are not found in animal cells.
So you should be able to answer this question here, which organellists found only in plant
cells, but the answer is chloroplasts.
How about a bonus question, what process occurs in chloroplasts?
The answer to that is photosynthesis.
So let's talk about some of these subcellular structures.
We've mentioned the cell wall.
That's the extra protection outside the plasma membrane.
That's fungi and bacteria and most protists have cell walls, but no animal cells have a
cell wall.
We just have cell membranes around our cells.
The nucleus in eukaryotic cells holds DNA.
Those DNA also consist of proteins that they wrap around to become chromosomes.
So together the DNA and the proteins are called chromatin.
This is then surrounded by the nuclear envelope.
The nucleolus is within the nucleus and this is the place where ribosomes are synthesized.
Then they're sent out of the nucleus later on, where their job will be to make proteins.
The mitochondria are an organelle that use glucose to make ATP, our own energy molecules,
adenosine triphosphate.
The process of using glucose to make ATP is called cell respiration.
Chloroplasts are within plant cells and also photosynthetic bacteria and protists as well,
like algae.
Chloroplasts can absorb sunlight and then use that energy and other things like carbon dioxide
to make sugar in the form of glucose and then they can store that later to make ATP.
That process of absorbing sunlight and using carbon dioxide to make sugar is called photosynthesis.
Only organisms that have chloroplasts with the pigment chlorophyll are able to do this.
A lysosome, shown here, is just basically a little bubble or a vesicle that contains digestive
enzymes.
The cell uses these lysosomes as kind of like housekeepers or janitors to engulf and digest
enzymes to help recycle molecules and they'll also engulf and digest old cell parts as well.
Photosomes are really tiny, again they're made in the nucleolus, then sent out and usually
attached to the ER though some are free-floating in the cytosol and they make proteins.
Their job is to string amino acids together in the right order according to DNA's code
so that we can make proteins correctly.
There's two types of endoplasmic reticulum or ER for short, rough and smooth.
The rough ER is usually found more near the nucleus in a cell and usually again has ribosomes
attached to it.
The smooth ER is usually found a little further out than the rough ER.
They do not contain ribosomes hence they look smoother.
They're involved in lipid synthesis and also detoxification and both of them are basically
membranes that are kind of folded into little tubes and act as kind of a transport network
within the cell.
The Golgi looks a lot like the ER in the fact that their little membranes folded into tubes
but they're usually further out from the nucleus, further out than the ER and closer to the
cell membrane.
They're kind of like the FedEx or the packing and shipping of the cell.
Their job is to finish off proteins to modify them, the final modification and then package
them into a vesicle by bubbling off a piece of itself as you see in the picture here and
then shipping that protein to where it needs to go.
The cereals are kind of neat looking little structures.
They're made out of protein microtubules that have an interesting shape to them.
We start off in the cell with a pair of them but that soon duplicates and when a cell is
ready to divide then we'll have a couple pair that migrate to opposite ends of the cell and
help the cell go through a process called mitosis or cell division.
There's also other cytoskeleton elements.
These are structural supports for the cell and they also help in mobility of the cell
as well.
There's different sized protein filaments here from microfilaments to intermediate filaments
and microtubules.
The central vacuole which is found in a plant cell stores both water and sugars and pigments.
That's a very quick rundown of the different cell components and organelles.
Speaking of plant cells, chlorophyll supplements are marketed as being able to energize detoxify
and help people heal wounds.
There is no evidence to suggest that any of these claims are true.
In fact because human cells do not contain chlorophyll, taking chlorophyll is actually
not supplementing anything.
Some athletes use creatine to increase muscle mass or allow for more powerful bursts of
energy.
Creatin is used during protein synthesis on ribosomes and by mitochondria in the making
of ATP.
Although creatine is normally found in the body, the effects of supplementing have not
been well studied yet.
With side effects like kidney failure, it's safest probably not to supplement creatine
at this time, above what you would normally obtain in your regular diet.
It's also common for athletes to drink protein supplements while exercising to enhance performance
and decrease recovery time.
This figure here shows data from one controlled study testing the effects of protein supplementation
during exercise in elite cyclists.
Elite cyclists ingested liquid supplements during a one week training camp.
One group of cyclists were given only carbohydrate supplements and the other group was given
carbohydrate with protein supplement.
The data shows the average power output during a test, a 5 minute all out cycling on day
one and then again on day six of training.
Power is a measure of energy used over time and is measured in watts.
So what does this data tell us about their average power usage on day one and day six?
While it appears that there's a slightly lower power usage by cyclists who receive protein
in their supplements compared with those that did not.
Scientists use the asterisks to show that a difference is statistically significant.
While weather ingested in food or supplemented in pills, one substances reach cells to be
used they must go across the cell membrane.
Molecules must cross that plasma membrane to gain access to the inside of the cell where
they can be used by those cell structures and organelles to synthesize cell components
or to be metabolized to provide energy for the cell in the form of ATP.
The chemistry of the membrane helps to facilitate the transport of some substances but then it
prevents the transport of others.
Substances that are able to cross reach what's called an equilibrium meaning they're equal
concentrations on both sides of the cell membrane.
Remember the plasma membrane consists of the phospholipid bilayer is differential permeable
meaning it will allow some things across but not all.
Hydrophobic substances which have characteristics more like fat meaning they're non-polar pass
through more easily especially through that hydrophobic interior than those that are hydrophilic.
Diseases like carbon dioxide, water and oxygen move freely across the membrane.
Larger molecules and charged molecules and ions cannot cross the lipid bilayer on their
own.
If these substances are to be moved across the membrane they usually need to go through
a protein which is embedded in the membrane so we would say that protein serves as a channel
or a carrier to allow those molecules to cross until again their concentration is equal on
both sides or they've reached equilibrium.
In cases where substances go across the cell membrane against their concentration gradient
proteins can serve as pumps to drive molecules away from equilibrium.
In passive transport molecules move down their concentration gradient without the use of
any extra energy meaning no energy molecules in the form of ATP or dentezing triphosphate
are needed for this process to happen.
Simple diffusion is one of these processes that's how carbon dioxide moves from where
it's more concentrated to where it's less concentrated across a cell membrane.
Here we see a closer look at that.
Carbon dioxide are very small hydrophobic molecules and therefore they go across that
membrane relatively easily.
See how there's more carbon dioxide and more oxygen on this side of the membrane.
They're moving from high concentration down their concentration gradient to low concentration.
Facilitated diffusion is another way that substances get across the cell membrane.
So a facilitator is somebody that helps a process occur and so proteins are the facilitator
in this process proteins facilitate the movement of certain substances down their concentration
gradient across the cell membrane.
Though things are going through a protein which acts as a channel or a carrier there's
no extra energy that's needed for this process because things are still moving down the concentration
gradient from where they're more highly concentrated to where they're lowly concentrated.
This might help with hydrophilic substances that would not go through the cell membrane
by themselves because of their properties so they go through the protein instead.
Again no extra energy is needed it's just the fact that they have to go through a protein
because the lipid bilayer won't let them through.
Osmosis is a special type of passive transport very similar to simple diffusion but it refers
specifically to the movement of water across the cell membrane.
So osmosis is the diffusion of water across the cell membrane from high to low concentration.
I like to say it's going from high water concentration to low water concentration.
Water likes to move from where there's a lot of water to where there's less water.
This can be a problem for some cells for instance how about an amoeba which is a type of protest
that lives in a fresh water pond an amoeba within its cytoplasm and cytosol would have
a lot of nutrients and substances and ions within itself.
And then there would be less of these things outside in the fresh water beyond so water
from the pond tends to move into an amoeba cell from where there's high water concentration
out here in the pond to where there's a lower water concentration in the cytoplasm of the
amoeba cell.
Now if that kept happening that amoeba could take on too much water and then burst luckily
the amoeba makes little packages that grab onto that excess water and then dump it out.
So once again the three types of passive transport diffusion facilitated diffusion and osmosis.
Where none of these take any extra energy in the form of ATP and all three of them the
substances move from higher to lower concentration.
Here's some questions which process uses transport proteins to move hydrophilic molecules through
the plasma membrane.
So the answer to that is facilitated diffusion.
How does water move if a cell is placed in salt water?
Well this can be a concern especially if organisms live in salt water or when we use IV fluids
in the medical industry.
Osmosis can cause water to move out of a cell if you place that cell in salt water because
there's more water in the cell and less water in the salt water.
Water will want to move out of the cell into that salt water down its water concentration
gradient.
Because of this when we use IVs in the medical industry we have to make sure that the IV fluids
have the same concentration of solutes as our fluids in our body.
That way we don't get cells taking on excess water or losing water.
A type of transport across membranes that does take energy is called active transport.
In order to power this process ATP or adenosine triphosphate is needed.
ATP activates the proteins that then act as a pump to pump molecules or substances against
their concentration gradient.
So in the picture here you see a potassium ion being pumped by this protein in a cell
membrane using ATP of course from where it's slowly concentrated to where it's more highly
concentrated.
So it's going against its concentration gradient that's going to take energy and yes that has
to happen often in our cells so cells do have to use energy to move things in and out.
So which one here describes active transport?
It's letter B. Potassium will move from low concentration to high concentration using ATP.
A common process using quite a bit of energy daily in our bodies doing just this is called
the sodium potassium pump.
These proteins constantly have to move sodium and potassium to their proper place on their
proper sides of the cells to maintain the charge on the inside and outside of cells.
This uses quite a bit of ATP each day just for this sodium potassium pump alone which
is a form of active transport.
Sometimes things are bigger than just little molecules moving in and out of cells.
Sometimes we have to get big things into or out of a cell therefore we need other processes.
One of those is called exocytosis.
Like ex or exit, these things are exiting the cell or leaving the cell.
So things are packaged into a little vesicle, a vesicle that contains phospholipids.
Those phospholipids will fuse with the membrane and then expel whatever it was inside that
vesicle.
Exocytosis is just the opposite of exocytosis so think EN for enter, these substances are
entering the cell.
In fact this is also how single cell organisms like protists called amoeba or our white blood
cells within our blood eat things by engulfing them.
They use endocytosis.
They send their phospholipids around the food particle.
And they engulf it and bring it in as a vesicle packaged.
Here's a video that you can watch if it doesn't run in the PowerPoint itself.
You can click on the YouTube link and watch that and it will show you animations of all
the different types of cell transports.
In closing, how do you actually know if supplements are getting transported into cells as many
of those supplements come in a large form and are they doing something that's actually
worthwhile for your health after all you're spending money on these things?
Well, the FDA or Food and Drug Administration does require scientific testing to prove the
safety and effectiveness of prescription and non-prescription drugs before they're released
to the public.
However, things that are labeled as dietary supplements don't have to be approved by
the FDA so it's not true for dietary supplements.
Even though people are using these things as medicines and sometimes taking them in massive
amounts, the claims that they make on the bottles are not necessarily tested or proven
through good scientific methods.
So look for these notices on some of the bottles like statements are not evaluated by the FDA
or this product is not intended to diagnose, treat, cure, or prevent any disease.
These types of statements should send up some red flags.
So what can you do?
Well your best bet is to evaluate the claims before you decide to use or ingest any type
of supplement.
Consult your physician or a trustworthy source such as a website and also you can check the
FDA website.
It keeps a record of supplements that are under review for causing adverse effects.
All in all it makes more sense to eat a healthy diet than to use high doses of expensive pills,
powders, and potions that haven't been evaluated for effectiveness or for even safety for that
matter and have not undergone rigorous scientific testing to see if they're actually making
a difference at all.
Then as we close be sure to review our learning outcomes for this chapter and go back through
and make sure that you can do each of these tasks as listed.